dan patrick how are you sir hi bud i'm
good
what's going on in your world dp that
was a hell of an interview you had
two days ago to say the least um
well
at what point did you realize that you
had uh quite uh a unique chit chat on
your hands there
dan with scottie pippen the other day um
i i think that he was welcoming when
you know sometimes when somebody's
available for an interview
they know it's just sort of i gotta
listen to all these questions same
questions over and over and over and
and i think scotty had been doing a few
interviews and he was selling his
bourbon
but it felt like he was not
excited to see me but at least welcoming
and
uh i just thought okay there's an
opening here i
i hope to be to be able to ask him
questions
without it being hey everybody's asking
that question or
let me go through the motions and answer
that and when i realized that he was
going to answer it
uh honestly at least i thought it was
honestly then i thought i might have
something there
i didn't realize it until about
five to seven minutes in that it's like
oh wow okay
yeah now now let's uh buckle up put the
hans device on i think we're gonna be
uh we're gonna be going toe toe-to-toe a
little bit well i mean i
imagine the first time you interviewed
scotty was when he was winning
championships with the bulls when it
first started right
when that's so you've been around
i interviewed him on the night that he
got drafted
right and i was there
covering it and he he had gotten traded
the night of the draft for oldham
polonies and i was sitting there next to
him and older in polonies
there's a group of reporters and they
they
you know old and had gotten drafted uh
by the bulls and scotty got drafted by
the seattle supersonics
and then they announced the trade those
guys just switched hats
and then they started talking about
their new respective teams
that was the first time i met him and
then after that subsequently with with
the chicago bulls
well uh because i i just seem to
remember you know the coup coach stuff
um where just the bulls writ large
not just you know scotty everyone had a
problem with kukoch
joining the team that he wasn't really
welcomed by the team
like at least that was the general sense
of everything at the time when he sat
and the fact that phil didn't turn to
scotty
um certainly at the time and in the
subsequent years never
never thought about it in in racial
terms and
so scotty mentioned that earlier this
week and just your simple
asking him to put a little bit more you
know uh detail behind it
certainly opened a door do you did that
surprise you or you did you
or had you already heard some of the
footsteps about that even before you
said something damn i had never heard
anything
like that and i i think when i saw
it in print in gq when he was asked
about that play and he said that you
know there was
racism involved in it and i thought i
wonder if scotty knows that he
just called his head coach a racist
right um
and i said you know to fritzy see him
get scotty on and
and tell him i i want to talk to him
about this quote i want to know
if he wants to add to it subtract from
it put it in context and
even when i started talking to him i
you know i i was able to
kind of feel it out of okay
does he even know what i'm going to be
talking about and and
the point was when i said let's bring up
1994 you know i've already done that
and i thought no no no we're going to
bring up the quote
and then you know i said you realize you
called phil jackson a racist he's like
yeah and then i go i don't know if he
knows the magnitude of this
to call your head coach one of the great
coaches in history
a racist and he didn't back down from it
and
you know he brought up the kobe bryant
situation where phil wrote a book and
that's why i said well that's not
that doesn't make him racist that means
he might be disloyal
and he was having nothing to do with it
and i thought okay this is
this is going to become a really big
deal and there are times in the
you know when i did the interview with
russell wilson in the moment
i realized this is this is going to be a
really big deal sometimes the person
you're interviewing
doesn't know it but i i think in those
terms when i'm
interviewing somebody and that is oh
that's going to stand out that's a quote
that's a headline it doesn't always
happen but in the moment sometimes
you're going oh boy
and i certainly felt that way with
scotty yeah and you're referring to when
russell was talking about his protection
and things of that nature
you you interviewed him just a couple
days after he won the walter payton man
of the year award right after the super
bowl when he was
sitting there and watching brady do what
he did which is definitely resonating in
the
in the quarterback world dan patrick
here on the rich eisen show
and again just to go into that response
that that that scotty did give you
uh about um phil and
and and why he thought that tony took
the shot
you also got uh uh a soliloquy from him
where again i i you know
know as an interviewer sometimes you
either have to keep pushing or you're
just like okay
um that's basically your answer what
what is he going on about the steve kerr
play and the cameras being
in the huddle and and that jordan knew
that the cameras were there and he could
control them
like thinking was he inferring that
jordan knew the last dance documentary
was going to come like decades later and
and he wanted to lay tracks about why he
wasn't getting the final shot to cover
for phil's racism is that
is that what i don't understand what he
was what was he saying there
you know that would that one felt like
it was a little
uh well a big leap from what we were
talking about through
hey i have a an isolated incident here
and
and it has to do with my because i was
bringing up that phil
designing a play for steve kerr
that michael didn't have a problem with
it and then that's when scotty said
no michael designed the play he knew the
cameras were rolling
he wanted to take charge of it it wasn't
phil who made that call
and i had never heard that before either
and uh i was there
with that in those moments right and i
never heard
anybody say after the fact you know uh
hey
michael's the one that called that play
not phil and here's the reason why he
did it
i don't know so yeah there are times
when you go okay i don't know
where he's going with this but i i do
want to say this in all fairness to
scotty yes
he i asked a question he gave me an
answer it's not like he tried to
like he truly feels this way and i know
no one has come to his
defense here but it doesn't mean he's
wrong in his mind what he
saw perceived what he felt what he heard
he he's right i was on the outside
looking in
and he is he has held on to these things
for over
25 years i i think that
i think the documentary hurt him a lot
more than we know
and i think it embarrassed him i think
when your kids
are watching this now it's one thing
that he went through it now his
children are watching this uh
you know he's going through a divorce he
lost a child
right uh you know there was a lot of
things that throw in there
and just to try to make sense of it but
i
i just didn't want to come off as tony
was
you know saying crazy things just to say
crazy i've been around rodman i've been
around tyson
i've been around guys who say crazy
things
i think scotty truly feels this and he
has been
he's been carrying this baggage for a
long time nobody asked for scottie
pippen to give a quote
once a year scotty will give a quote it
has to do with lebron and michael
or michael and lebron and then we go oh
do you hear what scotty had to say
nobody is asking him about this other
stuff
that happened and i think he got the
opportunity
and he wanted to make sure that people
got to hear his side of it
whether you believe it or not he wanted
to he
i think he wanted that that opportunity
and he got it
i don't think he regrets saying anything
on the show
no he he came out and he tweeted you
know basically that he
he he meant what he said you know
and um he's just answering the questions
y'all asking me is what he tweeted out
we wanted the headlines you got him dig
deeper to find out why i actually said
what i said instead of framing your
questions to get clicks it's all love is
what scottie pippen
had to say on on twitter after your
conversation and it is just
you know i mean the guy's top 50 you
know what i mean like of all time
and and you know we were going back and
forth here on the show just trying to
make heads or tales of all this
you know who else in the top 50 you know
is viewed as not the best player on his
team you know like we saw worthy and
mikhail right chris those are some names
that we saw on the list
yeah where are they kale kind of any of
those old celtics you know
and and how pippin is is carrying a lot
of this
and do you think some of this is lashing
out at michael too i mean he did also
have a couple broadsides in the
direction of mj
during that conversation with you yeah
when he said he was selfish
um for playing baseball you know that's
who mike yeah that's who michael
is um but i did say
you know michael never should have
brought up the contract that scotty
signed that
you know everybody knew and it was
embarrassing like that that
that that's not fair to scotty i didn't
think i thought michael was piling on
scotty but
but scotty you know i i think he was
like hey we we're not friends and we
don't socialize but we're fine we did
something
you know 25 years ago you know i moved
on with that
but he he hasn't moved on from that and
it feels like
you know there he's he's holding on to
some grudges
for a long time and um and now we're
kind of finding out he's kind of
illuminating us
on just how deep those are
and um i i don't think they're
they're remedied any anytime soon i
don't know if
phil jackson's going to reach out and
say like what do you say
right or right right and michael's not
going to reach out
you know michael's like hey like you
know that's how i treat all my friends i
give them
you know grief but i i don't know
it's just it's and you know we reached
out to steve kerr we reached out to phil
jackson we reached out to michael jordan
just to see if i wanted to be fair to
the story i wanted to be fair to him
but i like what do i ask phil jackson
yeah are you a racist i know it's just
i mean i know it's it's
it was a it's awkward but
i i appreciate all we want in our
business is somebody to be honest
or we we perceive them to be honest and
when they are
usually we criticize them and you know
after the fact
but if you say you're going to be honest
with me that's the only thing i can ask
for in an interview and scotty was being
honest
in his opinion and i i appreciate that
um i i'm yet to find somebody who backs
it up but that doesn't mean
somebody can't or won't isn't it amazing
dan it's a second straight uh
summer where the the dynastic bulls are
one of the top stories in the nba
you know and and you know and and and
how
we uh who talk sports for a living and
cover it
and fans who who who love it
um all would want their team to have the
same level of success as these bulls and
it just seems on occasion
how miserable everybody kind of was
it really is wild when you think about
it
i just thought that they would be a
little bit more
of a collective unit but when you
realize they didn't like the owner they
certainly didn't like the gm they didn't
like
who coach um and that's based off jerry
krause
you know jerry found tony cu coach going
to bring him over here and then
michael and scotty famously dogged him
you know in the olympics and
wanted to prove that this guy's not
great and here's scottie first year
here's his big opportunity and he gets
to take the shot
and now he's michael and you know phil
designs a play
uh you're down two games to none if you
lose this you got no shot
and they design a play tony hits the
shot
and you know i mean imagine if tony
doesn't hit the
shot what people would have said like we
give phil credit
he called the i mean coach was a better
deep shooter than scotty scotty wasn't a
great shooter he was
a very good scorer but if if if it
doesn't work then people are going to be
like why wouldn't you design a play for
scotty but it but it worked
as so many things that phil did uh you
know worked out that way but
um i i i don't know it's just it's it's
i love the character studies of people i
love
trying to understand somebody and and
when people say well
when you do an interview i said i just
listen like
who are you russell wilson can give you
he's like the derek jeter
of football players he he appears to be
giving you something he's very nice he's
available
he doesn't say anything and then when
you realize
oh boy russ is being honest here right
and like i almost had to say to him wait
you like debate you know what you're
saying right now like you
you feel like you're gonna be traded
well i don't know if you know i'm going
okay this is honesty and whenever you
get it
it is a treat and uh you just
you don't want to let it go and that was
the way i felt with scotty i didn't want
to stop the interview
but then he i think he got a little
angry at me when he said
you know do you understand english like
i couldn't comprehend what he was saying
which
i i do understand english i still
couldn't comprehend what he was
saying it was because i thought this is
mind-blowing here
it was it really was dan and then you
know and and just in
in you know i guess putting a a button
on all of it
in a way just talking about honesty from
interview subjects you heard brady on
the shop on lebron and maverick carter's
show
uh say that 90 of the time when he's
talking to the media he's not giving
anything on purpose
you know and um and yet this was a
imagine and you know the ten percent
where he was being honest when he was
talking about a team and that mf or is
going to st
you're going with that mf or over me and
it was you know refreshing here because
that's that is the way
that even goats talk that that's you
know that was why we
loved the last dancing you know the
moments that when jordan was handed an
ipad where the most delicious moments to
watch because you knew whoever was on
that ipad was about to get eviscerated
you know and so that is you know
i i i go back to the brady interview i
did
prior to the eagles super bowl and
i mean i was lucky i i for some reason
brady
was in a great mood and he came in and
and it was a couple of days before the
super bowl but
i i remember asking him a question it
was always something i wanted to know
and i said do you think that
one day that you and coach belichick
will sit down and open up the scrapbook
and talk about
all the memories and he looked at me
and he for a moment i thought he's gonna
say
uh what's the politically correct thing
to say or do i really want to say what i
what i think is true and he looked at me
and he goes
no like like like no
that was it yeah like no we're not going
to sit down and open up the scrapbook
and i went
wow i get and it just kind of hit me
that
brady brady was probably at his tipping
point of
you know i got to deal with this this
isn't fun um
i win and and we win and i you know i'm
the goat but you know
this isn't as fun as people think it is
that was their relationship dan that
that was their relationship sitting on
the set of the nfl 100 when brady when
the scrapbook was literally open
right the nfl films had a scrapbook
of called the nfl 100 all-time team and
belichick was there as an analyst now it
was the first day
and the first uh you know shoot so bill
might not have been as comfortable
being an analyst as he was in like
episode six but you could tell that the
two of them weren't going to sit there
and go down memory lane it could have
been because they were still in a coach
quarterback relationship
i don't know what to read into it but
maybe that's just not that what their
relationship
is and we just all think it's gonna be
like hey they're gonna sit back and open
a great bottle of wine or
you know whatever their their libation
of choices and just kick back and that's
just not it
you know maybe that's what happened with
the bulls
it's you know the lakers famously in the
80s like they
they just got tired of pat riley they
just they tuned him out
and and you know that's when he left uh
but they just got to the point where
like enough you know
yet coaches can overstay you know
normally the players change the coaches
stay but
you know after a while here's here's tom
who's been there for 20
years it's not like he hadn't heard
every story
uh every pep talk every we're on to you
know cincinnati like all of that stuff
there's not there's nothing new there
and i think with the bowls the same way
with
phil you just you kind of just get tired
of
of that and and maybe that's what's
happened with some of these players
that and i'm going to guess a lot of
great and i'm sure people
got tired of bellator uh uh parcells
where you go okay bill enough you know
and
and then we think boy these guys they're
friends and you got to be friends and
you get along and all those things
mike rodman never hung out with any of
the bulls uh
you know scotty didn't hang out with
mike mike hung out with other people
uh judd bushler and steve kerr probably
hung out together since they went to
school together but like you you start
to look at
a team and it's fragmented a little bit
of it's
two over here one over here three over
here
and you know after a while you're like
hey i'm tired of talking about how much
i hate coach why don't you
tell us how much you hate coach and then
suddenly there's six trophies in the
case
you know and it's kind of it's insane it
really is
wild it really is well we always go well
i would put up with that but in the
moment
like you say to tom was it worth it i'm
sure he's going to say yes
but you know there's a part of me that
probably says
i wish we could have had fun with this
because players talked about going to
new england like reggie wayne goes
i'd rather retire than him
right after being up there you know that
that's
it's indicting and and we can go oh come
on toughen up as a player
he's probably going man i i'm a hall of
famer i
i want to have fun i want to enjoy this
and i think that's what let tom
led tom do going to tampa it's like
god where can i have fun if you can't
have fun with bruce arians then you're
not going to have fun in the nfl and i
i think that played a large role of
like just enjoyment yes and the rest of
the quarterbacks who are currently in
their situations with hall of fame
careers or
on track for hall of fame careers seeing
what brady did and how much fun he's had
is what i think was definitely working
with russell wilson in his temples when
he chatted with you two days after
watching
brady win it in his first year somewhere
else and what what is informing maybe
roger's decisions whatever they may be
right now there's no question in my mind
dan about all that yeah and you think
you know all russ wanted was a seat at
the table with the seahawks that's
i was told that behind the scenes that
just can i
can i at least sit at the big table at
thanksgiving
do i have to sit at the kids table have
i earned that right
and i think that that then you see tom
brady
goes to a new team gets to bring in some
players that he wants to
and looks like he's having a whole lot
of fun winning another super bowl and
russ is going
there's mahomes in another super bowl
tom's winning another one
what am i doing and i think that's when
i saw him and he looked
miserable and it just so happened though
rich that we were supposed to have him
on
that friday of super bowl week and he
couldn't do it
scheduling wise but he said i promise
i'll join you guys on tuesday when i'm
back from the super bowl and i thought
all right you know whatever
and then as soon as i see him sitting
there with the commissioner and his wife
he's looking miserable
i go oh my god he's miserable super bowl
this is awesome i can't wait to talk to
him on tuesday
ross is miserable he's showing it he's
showing real emotion here
this will be great oh god
dp you're the best everything i know
it's amazing
uh great interview thanks for the time
you take care we'll chat soon
thank you guys talk to you soon that's
dp everybody
dan patrick hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here